[Musique]
en 1952 au coeur du printemps le 28 mai
le célèbre romancier john steinbeck
arrivent à charger ni où il va séjourner
trois jours c'est un homme illustre qui
a publié déjà une dizaine de romans dont
les célèbres raisins de la colère des
souris et des hommes que le cinéma
également fait connaître
la veille il était à paris à une
manifestation fomenté par les
communistes contre les états unis
soupçonnés d'utiliser des armes
bactériologiques au cours de la guerre
de corée un mort et des blessés parmi
les manifestants 200 blessés parmi la
police
moralement c'est un homme tendu parce
qu'il n'aime pas qu'on a un attaque son
pays
néanmoins dans sa citroën avec sa femme
hélène le long de la nationale le 5
il se détend parce que il sait qu'il va
y trouver des gens simples qui vont lui
permettre de changer d'idée
alors qui a invité johnny sbk châssis ni
celle oui jb professeur d'anglais au
lycée de poligny après la guerre
désireux d'écrire un mémoire de maîtrise
sur l'oeuvre de son romancier américain
préféré et qui donc a écrit à john
steinbeck
alors voici la maison dans laquelle
stenbeck a été invité au milieu d'une
atmosphère familiale très chaleureuse il
faut imaginer une rue me qui n'a rien à
voir avec la réhabilitation actuelle que
stenbeck se plaît à décrire comme une
rue très archaïque peuplé de tous les
animaux possible la création des vaches
des poules des canards des chiens des
chats beaucoup de ce qu'il appelle de la
poussière de fumier aussi louise ebay
avait été résistant il a organisé à la
fin de la guerre un des maquis qui ont
participé à la libération de mouthe le 4
septembre 1944
[Musique]
alors durant ces trois jours tembec va
découvrir que les gens qui l'accueille
si chaleureusement ont trois passions la
chasse le vin et la politique est plutôt
que de paraphraser ce que disent
ennebeck lui-même je préfère lire
quelques lignes tirées de l'article donc
ce soit en grèce au french la met les
tripes de la france rendez visite à un
homme chez lui il exhume du sol de sa
cave une bouteille pleine de terre sa
femme se précipitent pour poser sur la
table un fromage délicieux il regarde le
bouchon leur tourne le sens le passa six
invités la qualité du bouchon est le
premier signe de la qualité du vin puis
il remplit les verres c'est la
contrainte et qu'on boit silence alors
la troisième passion c'est la politique
1952 c'est le début de la guerre froide
qui oppose donc le bloc american blog
des alliés le bloc de l'ouest à l'
empire soviétique
la france est au milieu stenbeck
voudrais savoir de quel côté penche ses
amis tout récent des chars sidi stenbeck
leur dis vous avons sauvé quand même en
44 44 45
sous-entendu vous pourriez avoir un
minimum de reconnaissance en face les
gens de charline ils lui disent oui mais
vous êtes intéressé les américains vous
avez beaucoup d'argent nous ne voudrions
pas tomber sous votre tutelle stenbeck
renchéri en leur disant croyez-vous que
avec le bloc soviétique vous seriez plus
libre peut-être stenbeck publient dans
la revue call your cet article va créer
en arrivant sur les télex de paris 1 et
moi profond à lire stenbeck pollini est
un repère de communistes pollini est
également arriérés il faut donc contre
attaquer d'où la démarche de france
dimanche qui délègue de ses meilleurs
limiers lesquels sont chargés de faire
le tour de la ville en récoltant
d'autres témoignages et en montrant que
la petite ville de poligny est une ville
normale malgré ses conclusions de toute
façon j'ai toujours pensé que stenbeck
rendait un très bel hommage à la ville
de poligny
l'écrivain a fait rentrer ses polinois
dans l'oeuvre d'art une oeuvre
magnifiquement écrite est fait pour
l'éternité
[Musique]